welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home's newest
trailer confirms a bit about this movie
surprise cameos but in one big case an
even bigger secret completely by
accident it looks like by now you may
have seen a brazilian version of the
trailer in which as elektro sandman and
the lizard leap across the scaffolding
towards spider-man in the movie's
apparent final battle lizard dives like
he's in a world cup semi-final yeah it's
a bizarre recoil he is struck by some
invisible object that can only be
explained by ant-man by papa feige
sniping him for spoilers or most likely
the presence of andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man
in this shot but scrubbed from the
trailer footage are you sure about that
and his name is john c
it makes sense three versus three would
be much better composition than one
versus three lizard is clearly jumping
towards something in a different spot
than tom holland's peter parker is and
not only that i'm pretty sure i found
even more visual evidence that more
things were removed from this moment of
the trailer so toby and andrew's
existence in this movie while still not
confirmed by the filmmakers it's just a
foregone conclusion in the minds of most
fans so at this point i am honestly less
excited by their mere possible presence
in this film than i now am by why they
are actually in this movie and what that
tells us about the broad name multiverse
going forward but let's start with a
closer look at the shot in question
peter leaps from the head of the statue
of liberty toward electro sandman and
lizard who attacked from the surrounding
scaffolding peter seems to be aiming
directly for sandman while sandman hooks
his fist around from peter's left which
tracks with the next shot of peter
dodging that sand fist and then barrel
rolling over it before he dives but not
only does the lizard recoil from some
invisible hit in the brazilian trailer
lizard is lined up to strike someone in
a completely different spot than peter
is but also so is electro go through
this frame by frame you can see electro
is also pulling back his arm for a
strike against someone who is above
where peter is and then when peter does
that dive in the next shot you can see
elektro still above continuing to engage
someone else with an electric blast but
then because i'm a crazy person who
scrubbed through this footage even more
closely i found even more evidence of
possibly removed assets around peter
during this battle in the shot of peter
leaping off the statue of liberty head
if you look to the region to the right
of peter there is definitely an upward
moving smoky motion blur on the
background rim of that giant cap shield
as if something was here leaping out of
frame removed and when they had to
pencil back and what was behind it some
of the motion blur stayed also this
one's a bit harder to see but over on
the left side of the same shot a similar
motion blur seems to be distorting the
tip of lady liberty's spiky crown so
yeah two things leaping upward right
before tom holland peter parker does now
i thought this was just digital noise
but the distortion does not appear on
any other regions of the frame or on the
shot before this of peter landing on the
statue head which you'll notice does cut
to black as if to mask two other figures
landing on either side of peter right
after he lands who would then leap off
right before he leaps now when you go
back to the wide collision shot
everything in frame is moving with
debris lightning sand you can't really
discern any extraordinary motion blur
except there is a subtle odd downward
sweep of sandman sand in the bottom of
the frame like someone wafted it
downward in that blank region that the
lizard is approaching now there's also
this random detail a lot of you keep
asking me about this brown shape that's
hanging from the scaffolding to the left
of ned as mj falls some say this could
be an arm of some peter parker that
wasn't fully erased to be honest i don't
see how this is an arm it looks like a
bundle of rope to me and like if a vfx
artist goes to the effort to erase an
asset they don't get tired halfway
through and then decide to recolor it
brown so i don't know what this is i
just don't think it's another spider-man
though now two months ago after andrew
garfield discussed some rumored set
leaks from no way home on the tonight
show with jimmy fallon we here at new
rockstars did a vfx analysis on some
online claims over whether or not the
set footage of garfield was doctored now
i won't show that full footage here but
i will tell you it does seem to match
the scaffolding that surrounds a statue
of liberty in this trailer and a special
thanks to exter the world's largest
smart wallet brand for sponsoring this
video they design the smartest wallets
in the world which you can track with
their solar powered tracker worldwide
this is the tracker it's solar-powered
it's discreet it's light and you get to
slip it in your wallet and then if you
ever have trouble finding your wallet
your tracker is here to help you find it
instantly it's voice-activated and
solar-powered two hours of sunshine give
it a three-month charge so all you gotta
do is download the chippelo app on your
phone and then you can ring your wallet
from your phone or your phone from your
wallet it works with google home alexa
and siri so
siri where's my wallet
[Music]
i hear it
i found it and extra slim profile
wallets of which this is one they're
awesome they're made of premium leather
they have rfid protection and you can
use this little button to
instantly fan out your cards so no more
overstuffed wallets no more giant lumps
in your back pocket check out extra
wallets with the link below and earn an
additional discount with our code at
shop.exter.com new rockstars that's code
rockstars to maximize your savings at
shop.exter.com
new rockstars but beyond the visuals of
this scene there are some contextual
clues in the trailer that help us
understand why toby and andrew would
even show up in this movie obviously mj
falls from the scaffolding in slow
motion that closely mirrors gwen stacy's
death drop in the amazing spider-man 2.
and while the trailer very clearly makes
it seem like it's tom holland in his new
spidey suit reaching out for mj here it
also does read like a chance for andrew
garfield to redeem himself by saving mj
and if they could scrub and swap out
other stuff in this trailer it's not too
hard to imagine a different spider-man
hand reaching down in the theatrical
version also there's a line where doc
ock sees tom holland's face and says
you're not peter pogba reminding us that
some toby maguire peter parker exists
somewhere in this merged spider-verse
also peter mentions his spider bite to
mj not that big of a deal but it is
something that has only come up once in
the mcu before this and it seemed like
the mcu was just gonna move on from
peter's origin but hearing it now
suggests that this line could be setting
up this peter finally detailing his
superhero origin in no way home which
could come in the form of a conversation
with other peter parkers whose varying
bites uncle ben deaths and web shooting
abilities are something we're all eager
for them to compare notes on ultimately
i think this could tell us why alternate
peters could be so important to
crossover into the mcu not just to blow
our minds it's gonna do that but peter
needs to learn from other versions of
himself that it is impossible to have it
all something toby maguire peter learned
in his movies and that sometimes you
might be unable to save someone you love
which andrew garfield peter parker
learned in his movie i mean the fact
that this battle restages gwen stacy's
death drop with mj hints that a key
mechanism for andrew and toby's returns
will be to give these past peter parkers
one last chance to redeem their biggest
mistakes for andrew peter that was
letting gwen die obviously and for toby
peter that was letting his mentors die
lying to his best friend letting
vengeance open him up to toxic
influences and turning his mary jane
against him while mj forgave peter in
that final scene they don't kiss they
don't get engaged it's really a muddy
we're still working through this kind of
ending one of the reasons i think sam
raimi's spider-man 3 is super
underappreciated and a potential mixed
bag of a future for that version of
peter parker that this movie could
revisit like imagine toby mcguire peter
parker never truly fixed things with mj
and he now counsels tom holland peter
parker a younger peter to just retire
early enjoy a normal college life
despite that pretty crappy advice mr
stark gave you in civil war when bad
things happen they don't always happen
because of you kid you deserve your own
life so while many of us are expecting
to hear the line with great power comes
great responsibility and no way home it
wouldn't surprise me to hear tobey
maguire peter parker offer a more
evolved take on that famous adage that
only an experienced spider-man could
speak with authority on that really our
greatest responsibility is knowing when
to give up that power so this idea of
learning from the past one universe
building on the knowledge gained from
other universes i think that's going to
be the driving theme as the mcu expands
into a multiverse of cooperative
cross-universe team-ups like the
spider-verse like the captain britain
core like the fantastic four arguably
what kang has already accomplished with
the council of kangs you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis and breakdowns of everything
spider-man related thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you